[Music]
so thank you again for being here I'm
excited to talk to you today about kind
of the basics of our studio konnekt
internals and sort of what's going on
behind the scenes in the server and how
you can manage it and interact with them
so we're going to cover a few different
topics today so we'll start with just a
basic introduction to what is our studio
konnekt so if you're unfamiliar or that
you're new to this product and you know
cover that briefly secondly we will talk
about installation and setup kind of
what you need to do and things that you
need to be aware of in order to
configure the product and then lastly
we'll dive a little bit deeper into a
few different areas on some details
about how the product works and some
some nuances that you should be aware of
as I mentioned we will be doing a
follow-on webinar to this one in a
couple of weeks and in that webinar rut
will actually go into a lot more detail
on this third section or more details
and some more things that you should be
aware of if you want to manage this
product in a production environment and
it will conclude with a demo of the
product so that if you haven't seen it
yet you'll have an opportunity to get a
feel for what it does
so our should connect is an enterprise
publishing and management platform it
can handle static and dynamic content
basically anything that you can create
with our including documents
presentations dashboards and china
applications and so one of the nice
things about this is that it has
push-button publishing from the arc
Studio IDE and so if you're using a
recent version of the IDE you'll see
this little publish button that you see
here at the top right you should be able
to click that and click publish to our
studio Connect and if you register an
account on our studio connect server
you'll be able to seamlessly publish
documents and are marked on documents
and shiny applications anything else
that you're producing in the IDE into
connect it is an on-premises enterprise
product so this is not an open source
product but it is something that you can
install behind your firewall and it's
not a hosted environment and lastly it
obviously is is meant for kind of
sharing data science artifacts within
your organization so this is a Seikh
is kind of what most of your users are
going to see when they look at our
studio konnekt so on the right here this
is kind of the full panel and you can
see the majority of the space is picking
up on this lower left here by the shiny
application this is what your users are
you would be creating to share within
your organization up at the top you can
see we have kind of settings toolbar and
some management there at the content and
then over on the right you've got your
settings panel which is where you can
manage in this case the performance of
the shiney application you can see
another screenshot separately on the
left here of what it looks like to
manage the access controls of different
content on the server as well so this is
one of the key features of Connect is
that you're going to be able to go in
publish directly from the IDE and now
you have this web interface to be able
to go in and navigate and manage your
content and set who should be able to
see it and who shouldn't so in order to
get started with our studio connect your
first just going to want to download and
install it so you can download it from
this link here or you can find it on our
website a similar link that will let you
register and download before you get
started with connect you will need to
install our and depending on which
distribution you're using you can either
do that from your package manager
most have are or if you're looking for a
particular version of our you can
compile it from source and then lastly
connect is made available as either a
Debian or an RPM installer file and so
the installation should be pretty
seamless you should just be able to any
of the listed distributions here Ubuntu
12 14 or 16 or red hat or CentOS six and
seven you should just be able to run a
commander to to be able to get connect
and any dependencies that we have up and
running on your servers so at that point
you should actually have connect
installed and it should be no more
difficult than that but one of the first
things that you're going to want to do
is go in and start configuring the
server and so you can see here an
example on the right of what a
configuration file looks like and so
these are just some of the basic
settings that you might be interested in
managing on the server and so at the top
here you can see you've got your cinder
emails it's the email address from which
you'll be sending any outgoing email on
the on the server will be sent you've
got your address which is the URL where
users should
expect to come back to your server and
then you got basic settings here around
you know which ports do you want to be
listening on if you want to use SSL you
can set up your certificate your key and
the new classic and figure out
indication here which is what we'll talk
about here at a moment all of these
configuration options are detailed here
at this link and this will go into
detail every single configuration option
on the server and how you can tune and
manage just about anything on the server
there all of these are managing the
config file at this location at CR
studio konnekt slash our studio konnekt
at GCF gene and so this is where you'll
spend the majority of your time
configuring the connect server and it's
a good idea to keep an eye on the log
file down here at the bottom the star
log our studio connect out log this is
where we're going to print out any
warnings or issues that we've
encountered during the installation
process or you know as you're
configuring the product if there's a
syntax error or if you've made a mistake
we plus you know that is in this log
file here so it's a good idea to keep an
eye on the log file as you're tweaking
settings on the server alright so this
is then an overview of the
authentication options on the server so
at the top is the default which is
connect built-in authentication system
and so you can have these basically we
have of a full-fledged off system in
connect that handles password resets and
user self registration and the whole
nine yards our email confirmation and so
you can use that built-in authentication
system if you don't already have an
existing off environment that you're
wanting to use but most enterprise
organizations are already going to have
some database where they keep all their
usernames and passwords and often that's
LDAP or Active Directory both of which
are supported and you can see here that
if you set up with an environment that's
called double bind or with a service
account then you're actually going to be
able to also access the LDAP groups and
be able to search for other users in
your organization within the product and
so that's a nice way to set up cut up
the full-fledged LDAP environment
alternatively if you're using Google
then we do support Google OAuth 2 so if
your organization uses you know Gmail
and Google accounts to manage
their authentication you can certainly
use app with internet we also support
Pam which is the basic mechanism for
logging into Linux servers if you're
unaware and lastly we have another
mechanism called proxy authentication
compact authentication is kind of the
catch-all so if you're using an off
system that's not explicitly supported
then you can actually set up a proxy
server that intermediate between your
your clients and the connect server and
basically just instructs connect as to
which users using the server currently
and so that's a way that if you use some
other off system that you'd be able to
still continue to teach connect which
user is currently using the server
excuse me all right so the next step
then once you've set up authentication
oh and one more point on authentication
actually before I move on we do not
support off migrations so if you start
with connects built-in authentication
system and then we move into elba you're
going to find that the you know the
users that were working in connect built
an authentication system don't exist in
LDAP so we can create kind of a
split-brain mentality and so Dex create
some problems on the server and it is a
very useful solution so we don't
explicitly support off migrations so I
would encourage you to go ahead and take
the time to get the off system set up
correctly on day one and don't plan to
you know kick the tires on that mom can
I spilt an off system and then you know
a week later move to held up or anything
because the easiest option is really
just going to be to wipe the server and
start over because you're going to
you're going to continue to have
problems if some of your users are on
one off system and some around another
so do go ahead and just take the time to
get that right that'll create the best
experience for you if you just go and
get that set up on day one alright so
the next step then once you have
authentication is you can actually go
ahead and create your first account on
the our studio connect server so you
just access connect in the browser using
whatever port you defined in your config
file the default is 39:39 and so if you
hit the server on that port and you know
assuming there are any firewalls in
between you you should just be able to
access the connect server and you can go
to log in and that will give you the
opportunity then to either login using
existing credentials if you're using
something like
that or Active Directory you'll just
enter your your username and password
from your organization or of course with
OAuth you just click through and go
through the Google OAuth flow if you are
using connect built-in authentication
system then you'll use you can create a
register an account here and you can
define the username and password that
you want and you know set up your email
address and all that sort of information
one thing to be aware of here is that
the first account created does become an
administrator so once you've installed
the server and you've configured it the
way you want go ahead and create the
account and that first account is going
to be an admin user subsequent accounts
will not by default the admin users you
would you have to explicitly the support
or promote them if you wanted the user
to be an admin user so but this will
give you full reign over the server as
your the first account on the server so
that will give you access to some
different views inside the server such
as this one so here we're looking at the
metrics on the connect server and so we
have a system that tracks kind of some
basic metrics about the server CPU and
RAM some of the user counts against you
know how many users your license for
information like this
what kind of our processes are running
at that time and things like that so you
can go in and manage all of these or
kind of going to look and inspect all
these different metrics here and then
you'll notice there's a Settings button
up at the top there and that's real
configure here the next step which is
configuring email so email is a pretty
important system in connects email is
used for account confirmation it's used
for the delivery of reports and if there
ever any reports that have errors when
you any scheduled reports that have
errors then we would send you an email
about that as well
note that account confirmation isn't
necessary if you're using an external
off system like LDAP we assume that
you're all that system already has
trustworthy email addresses but if you
are using connect built in off system
then we will need to use email to
confirm users accounts as they create
them so this page is then where you
would go ahead and configure your email
settings and you can either set up send
mail as your email sender or SMTP if
you're unfamiliar with all this
if you're in an organization list of
that's medium sized or larger it's
likely that your organization probably
already has an SMTP server set up or
emailing somewhere and so if you just
ask your IT group they would probably be
able to tell you the information that
you need to be able to point connect the
appropriate SMTP server one thing to be
aware of here is that some SMTP servers
are particular about which email
accounts they're willing to send from
and so you should be aware of that
because make sure that the sender email
configuration option that you set in
your config file make sure that that's
going to play nicely with the SMTP
server that you put in some SMTP servers
will refuse to send emails from certain
domains or from you know users that they
don't know we trust so you need to be
aware of that
but regardless of how you configure it
this is where you would configure it and
you've got this test email option up
here which would send an email to you to
confirm that the Dinos up and running
now once you've done that your server is
actually up and running so your server
is live and you can actually start
inviting users to use it they can start
publishing content deploying new
documents and training applications and
all of the above
so you think at that point you are up
and running and you can get people in
the system but it might be useful to go
back especially if you're new to connect
I think it might be useful to go back
and kind of review what is it that we've
just done and what actually is going on
under the hoods of all this work that we
just did so connect under the hood is a
server with an HTTP API there's a web
application front-end which using
screenshots of previously it's an
enterprise authentication system which
we've discussed a bit there's an AR
execution engine and really if you kind
of distill connect down to its bare
bones the server portion of connect is
really just responsible for spinning up
our processes at the appropriate time
and so that's a lot of what of what
Connect is actually about and what it's
doing and so we'll talk about some of
the different types of our processes
that it can spawn and the situations in
which it's going to do so
and then lastly there is a database
component and currently at the time of
this recording in early 2017 we only
support sequel Lite as our database and
so that's an internal system that you
don't need to configure or manage but
others will be coming shortly so if you
prefer my sequel or Postgres or Nvidia
above we will be supporting those in the
near future and all of this again is
going to be detailed in the admin guide
which is where most of the links that
I've shown you today have been pointing
but this would be the kind of top-level
view of our admin guide if you want to
learn more about any of these different
systems feel free to go to this and
start praising the admin again so one of
the things that's important to
understand a bit about is how we're
running our processes inside of Connect
so connect as as I mentioned is largely
about spinning up and shutting down our
processes the appropriate time and that
might be triggered on demand so as a
user goes to visit a training
application if there's not already a
process running for that training app
then we might go ahead and spin up in
our process at that time to serve that
request or it could be on a schedule so
if you configure a report to repeat
every week then we'll go ahead and
schedule that our process to come up
with the appropriate time we do use a
sandbox environment with when we spawn
every our process and so behind the
scenes what this is using is called an
unshare with a per process bind mount
and these are just kind of some Linux
system internals but that allows you to
isolate the data and code from other
applications so what happens is when you
deploy code onto the connect server your
code is going to run in the sandbox
environment where you don't have access
to anyone elses source code or data and
so that's valuable because that allows
you to kind of ensure that you know even
if you might have varying levels of
trust among the users or the publishers
on the system you can still ensure that
you know nobody's going to be sniffing
out each other's code or data or
anything like then one caveat here we
are not using docker that sounds a bit
like docker if you've used our before
but we're using kind of a lighter weight
version of talker and the motivation
there is that we don't want to interfere
with whatever you're using docker for or
require
their versions of doctor on your server
that might interfere with some of the
other work that you're doing there so we
have our own kind of internal system
uses some of the same mechanisms of
docker but it's a little bit more
lightweight and you know more interfere
with with whatever else you're doing on
the server and one caveat here is that
this does require route and so this is
the reason that Connect will require
some root privileges at runtime is
because in order to do these bind mounts
and kind of secure users from one
another
we will need to run that processes route
so a little bit more about the our
execution
one of the nice things about Connect if
you've used a system like Chinese server
of shiny silver Pro is that connect will
actually capture all of the our package
dependencies for you and they'll be
provisioned for you on the server and so
what this looks like and I'll show you
this in a moment in the demo but when
you publish from the IDE we're going to
capture every single version of every
single package that you're using in your
code and then we'll recreate that exact
environment on the server and even we
can try to align the different versions
of our that you might have installed in
the server so if you do have multiple
versions are installed we'll actually
try to identify the one that's closest
to the version of our that the client is
using and then we'll try to replicate
that environment there on the server so
what this all creates is an environment
in which when your users publish from
the IDE if they're much more likely to
have success running their code on the
server environment because they have all
the right versions of all the right
packages and even the right version of
our and so there's a high likelihood and
there's a pretty good confidence that
whatever they've been running locally is
going to continue working on the server
one other thing that you should be aware
of as you're setting up the server is
some of the data storage implications
and so we store data in varlet our
cities connect by default but that is
configurable in the in the settings file
and you can see down at the bottom I
have a pointer down to the specific
section of the admin guide that's going
to detail how you manage and configure
all these directories that you're going
to store data in we recommend starting
off with 50 gigabytes or more and really
that's that's a pretty nebulous
recommendation so some organizations if
you if you find that you're often
deploying China applications or are
marked on documents that have big CSV
files associate
with some more big data sets then you
might actually burn through that
disk-based pretty quickly alternatively
if you're using largely external
databases and you're not really
publishing data you know as you publish
your code then you may find that 50 gig
bike is plenty for you know dozens of
users so you really just need to kind of
judge you know based on how your users
are going to use the system but if you
have the option of doing something
that's actually a little bit more
flexible or file system that can be
expanded in the future you might find
that that's probably the best option for
you to give you the most flexibility
moving forward the one caveat here again
eventually we will not have this hard
requirement in sequel Lite but as long
as you're using the sequel Lite database
that does need to be stored on the local
disk that can't be on a network share
but all the other data that we store in
Barlow box to do connect can be on a
network drive and again all of this is
captured in this link that I have down
below and so if you want to go through
this on your own time feel free to go to
that and we even go through the example
of how to put your database in one
directory and put everything else on
another directory alright so a little
bit about the user roles that exists on
this server so first of all on the left
here you can see these are the different
kind of global user roles that a user
can have that an account can have on the
server so you start off the highest
level as an admin and again the first
user created on the server is going to
be an admin account and so the admin hat
does have all privileges on the server
so they can access anything that they
want they can you know do anything that
they want on the server but a regular
actions are on it and by a regular here
I mean any action that they wouldn't
freely have had access to so if they go
to view a report for instance that they
don't normally have Aiko's do they
aren't normally registered as a viewer
on that report we're not going to freely
show them that report but instead you
know we would show them kind of an error
message saying you're not authorized to
view this report however as an admin
they do have the privileges to add
themselves as a view or show that report
and then view it so of course they can
see anything that they want on the
server but by adding themselves as a
viewer that is an audit in action and so
that will be law
that will be tracked and so hopefully
that kind of creates a nice balance
where the admins are able to navigate
the server however they need to to help
users and unblock people but are not
freely you know overwriting their their
responsibilities or their privileges the
next level down is a publisher so a
publisher is one who can upload new
content and so this is someone who's
going to be authoring our code and
publishing it onto the server and then
if you are someone who is a consumer
they can just see the content that
exists on the server but they're not
allowed to publish new content under the
server so those are the global user
roles and that every account is going to
fall into one of those three buckets on
an application though each of these
users could be registered as either
collaborator or a viewer and so a
collaborator is someone who can publish
new versions or manage settings of
content or even refresh for instance
documents so if you had a collaborator
in the document they would be able to go
in and help you tune that document they
would be able to add new viewers and
collaborators they would be able to
refresh the document etc and I will
contest that the publishing new versions
the collaborative publishing from
multiple endpoints it's not a seamless
experience today
but that is something that we're working
to improve in the next version so that
you would be able to have multiple users
all publishing to the same endpoint and
then have that work fluidly the next
level down would be a viewer and this is
someone who can only see the existing
content they're not authorized to make
changes to that content and so you think
any of these three user roles could be
registered as a viewer because you know
any any user on the system could be
registered as a viewer however in order
to be a collaborator you have to be a
publisher or a nut and a viewer cannot
be registered another collaborator and
so this will hopefully all become pretty
pretty clear to you once we start using
the system and then hopefully this will
become pretty transparent one more piece
to note here is the IDE integration I
mentioned we have push button publishing
from the IDE and this is a screen shot
of kind of what configuring that looks
like it is all built on top of the RS
connect our package was just an open
source our package that's available on
cran and so what that means is that
everything that I'm going to show you
from the IDE you can't actually do on
the command line
in an open source environment you don't
have to use their studio IDs you don't
want to but if you are using their FTP
ID that's probably going to create the
most seamless and streamlined experience
for you and so you just go to tools
global options publishing and that will
allow you to register a new connect
server you give it the URL and then it
will ask you to log in and that'll allow
you to link your account to the connect
server it does share the same HTTP API
that the browser uses and so whatever
Network requirements you have to allow
your users from the browser to access
the web application the same
requirements would exist here from the
our studio environments and one thing to
be aware of is custom certificate
authorities and if that doesn't mean
anything to you don't worry about this
it probably doesn't apply to 90% of you
but if you are using a custom
certificate authority in your
organization be aware that while your
browsers may be trained to trust that
custom CA your our studio environment
may not be so our studio uses different
networks mechanisms like curl for
instance to establish network
connectivity and so if curl is not
already instructed to trust your custom
CA you may find trouble hitting a custom
SSL certificate and so just just check
on that when you're connecting from the
ID because that's the problem that some
people have run into when they're using
not properly signed or internally find
certificates so finally I wanted to get
into a little bit of kind of telling you
what to expect or on what users or it
might be publishing under the connect
server so if you're new to our or you
know your NIT and you can kind of past
with setting up the connect server but
you're not really familiar with the
ecosystem I wanted to give a little bit
of information about sort of what you're
going what you should expect to be
managing on your server here so first of
all you're going to see some shiny
applications so shiny is an open source
or package that allows you to create
interactive web applications one of the
caveats around Chiney from hosting
environment is that it does require an
interactive or runtime and then it's
going to proxy traffic back and forth
between that our process and the browser
and so as the user makes changes in
their browser it's going to use a
WebSocket to send traffic back to the
r-process
the r-process is going to do some work
and send information back to the browser
so you do need a live our process
running any time that any user is
looking at a shiny application and so
you can kind of budget for that in terms
of you know what the workload is going
to be or what the hardware requirements
would be for your server and then lastly
if you've used Chinese server for
hosting Chinese applications in the past
we envisioned connect a roughly a
superset of Chinese server with a couple
of caveats but but basically if you've
used to any server open source then what
connect is going to give you over shiny
server open sources authentication the
user self management as you've seen here
in the dashboard and we'll show you the
demo here in a moment how the users can
kind of manage the content themselves
scaling of into multiple processes as a
shiny application so now if you've got
many users or a CPU intensive
application you can scale that across
multiple processes and then obviously
the hosting of other content types like
our markdown and static documents
secondly you're going to see some our
markdown content and so our markdown is
a report that never leaves code and
prose typically but there are a lot of
different output manifestations that are
markdown can take on so you can see some
of these over here on the right you can
create dashboards in our markdown slides
plots reports notebooks and you can even
enter we've some shiny components within
our markdown we create an interactive
report typically these are rendered to
HTML but you also have the option of
rendering these to PDF or even Microsoft
Word and so this is another format that
is popular in our environment and that
you'll see people using and publishing
under the connect server one other thing
to be aware of is a concept called
parameterised or markdown and so this is
something that has actually existed in
our markdown for years now but there
hasn't really been an environment that
really allowed this to shine and so I'll
give you a demo of this here in a moment
but parameterised archive is a really
neat feature and if you are kind of the
IP person in your group you might
actually be able to kind of take this
back to your data scientist and
introduce this to them and teach them
something new here because a lot of data
sciences have not actually used this
before and it's a pretty powerful
framework so basically the idea of
parameterize our markdown is that you're
using a regular our markdown report but
you're going to inject a couple of input
parameters into the document and so you
can see here in the screenshot on the
right and example where we've created a
report that analyzes some stock ticker
symbol and you know whatever analysis is
meaningful to perform on the stock
ticker symbol we're able to do here but
what's interesting then is that you can
actually pass in a stock ticker symbol
and kind of have that be a parameter
that's arbitrary and maybe even a date
range for instance in this case and you
can pass this in as inputs into this
document and then render the document in
light of those input parameters and so
it's still going to output an HTML or
PDF or a Microsoft Word document
whatever it is that you configure jerem
worked on document to create it could be
a report could be a dashboard it could
be anything it is still scheduled system
and I'll show you an example of that
momentarily but what that does is it
allows other users to interact with the
document in kind of a more tailored way
and so you're able to go in and say you
know these are a couple of inputs that I
want people to be able to change on the
document let them kind of tweak some of
those things in a very kind of
well-defined way in structured way
they're able to kind of simulate or kind
of you know extreme meta analysis for a
particular set of inputs so this is kind
of a nice intermediary between static
our markdown and something full-fledged
interactive like shiny but I'll show you
a demo of this here in a moment
all right so let's move on to the demo
so here you can see I'm in the our
Studio IDE and hopefully this is a
something to familiar to many of you so
this is basically where we are going to
do our analysis we're going to create
our artifacts in this case you can see
I've created a plot over here this is
using ggplot and so in this case I'm
just going to kind of do the simplest
example first which is to publish a
static plot so this is a static image
here I'm gonna go ahead and publish that
up into the connect server so I click
publish I'm going to publish to connect
I'm going to find the connect server
that I have I've got a bunch registered
I'm going to find the connect server
that I'm interested in and I'm going to
call this my GZ plot to plot
click publish and then what you'll see
here is in my browser it opens setup and
I now can configure access controls by
default it's going to be just me but I
could set that to be all logged in users
have access or maybe everyone has access
this is a public document or I could
specifically say particular users have
access so this case helps go and make it
public and then this is who can change
the plot so this is these are the
collaborators here and whatever I'm
happy with my configuration I can say
and publish that plot and now it's live
and other people could be could access
that on the server so this is useful to
some extent for aesthetic plots if you
have aesthetic graphic that that you
want to share with other people this is
how a centralized environment where you
can do that and obviously if this were
an HTML HTML widget or something that
we're a little bit more interactive you
could also do that but this is nice
because now you're not emailing around
old versions of reports or old versions
of graphs but instead you can kind of
centralize everything under a single
server so that is handy but but it's a
bit limited right there's you can't
schedule a static plot to update there's
not really a whole lot you can do with
the static plot so so you know this
doesn't really a lot kind of shine but
it still has some utility so let's look
at something a little bit more complex
so that allow connect to kind of
showcase more of its features so in this
case I have a parameterised our merchant
document and so the way the primary our
markdown works is that I'm able to
interact with it locally here I can knit
with parameters and what I actually done
which through this first what I'm
actually done here is I've created two
different parameters in my document this
was in the UML header at the top of our
mark some duck so I have two different
parameters the first one is called state
and it has these options the second one
is called year and it has these options
so these are both going to be select
boxes or drop-down boxes and I can run
this locally I can same it with
parameters and now it looks like this I
can go ahead and select the state from
my list that I chose I can select a year
from the list that I chose and then I
can click on it and that will go out and
build the document
using my custom input parameters and so
here you are with the state that I
selected in the year that I selected and
there's kind of a handy way to kind of
customize a document now you can see I'm
looking at all this data that's specific
to Pennsylvania at the state that I was
interested in so this is a pretty handy
way to work but it's kind of a limited
value when you're using it locally
however I can publish this now and in
this case are not actually already
published it but I can publish this now
and to the our studio konnekt server so
let me go ahead and update that and I'll
show you what this looks like so one of
the things to be aware of here is as
we're going to deploy this is going to
actually go through and figure out all
so first of all bundling up all of the
data that's associated with this report
and so I skipped over that when the
publish dialog should shown you that but
basically it captured the fact that I'm
listing a CSV file on my code and so it
assumes you should probably you probably
want that CSV file to be included with
you I referenced a couple of different
our data files and it captured those
it's file and it says it's list to fast
and it said that you wouldn't transfer
those up looking so what that means now
in this mania is it the first thing it
did is it created a this bundle and it
uploaded it and that includes all of the
data that I have all of the code that I
have everything that I need to run this
document and then as it goes on it
actually inspects all of the packages
that I'm using in my document and all
the dependencies of those packages and
all of the versions of each of those and
so every particular version of every
particular package that I have installed
that I'm using as a part of this
document is going to be captured here
and then recreated automatically on the
server environment and so you can see
that's what it's doing here is it's
transferring basically transferring my
environment from my local machine on to
mount the remote or all of these
packages and then it's going to deploy
the document and so now that's what
you're looking at here is this document
here and so we'll go ahead and look at
that in the context of this panel here
so
what's nice now is that Kinect has
actually given you the option of kind of
tuning your parameters here and so this
is going to be available to every
collaborator in the system that has
access to this report so it's nice about
this and in business but you do have the
same settings you have control here so
that you can tune who has access to this
document
but when Frank Tenney collaborate on the
system would be able to go in and start
changing these parameters and running a
report that's relevant to them and so
now you're entering a world where not
only are you empowering your data
scientist to share work with one another
but you're also empowering non data
scientists people who aren't comfortable
with are or are familiar with are to be
able to go and generate analysis of
their own so let's look at the version
of this report for California for
instance so if I'm someone who doesn't
know are but I'm interested in
healthcare in California then I'm now
able to just click a couple buttons
click around the report and now I'm able
to inspect this report as run on the
particular data set that interests me
and said that that has a lot of value
but it gets even better
because now if this report is something
that I'm actually really interested in I
can go ahead and save that and I can
either decide that this is going to be
public this is relevant to everyone on
the server or this is relevant to me in
this case I'll just say it's table just
relevant to museums someone is
interested in healthcare in California
and now I've got this Callie a variance
for this version of the report that's
based on California and now I can
actually go in and I can schedule that
to repeat and so let's say I want to
know the updated healthcare information
for this report or you know from this
data I want to get that every Monday at
9:00 a.m. showing that weekly every week
on Monday I am and I want to even get an
email of that when it's available or
maybe I can add other people in my group
who might be interested in receiving
that email and so this is a really
convenient way then of being able to
allow users who you know haven't written
a single line of code to be able to
customize some data to of the things
that are interesting to them and then
even be able to subscribe to updates on
that date and so now you can imagine
that as you tap into some of the data
that's available in your organization
you could create some really
and powerful reports that you can now
schedule to distribute out to your group
or to a wider audience that might be
interested or just let them kind of
inspect and find the things that they're
interested in themselves so this is a
bit of about how you might use connect
one of the other features that's
actually going to be available here in
the next version that we're releasing
this week is this feature here where you
can manage source versions and so you
can see the latest version of this
document was published four minutes ago
that's the one that we did live but
there are older versions that I
published previously and what I can
actually do is I can go back and roll
back to a previous version so I had
introduced a bug in this version that I
just published I can actually go back
and say you know I actually want to
activate this version instead and roll
back to a previous version or roll
forward to embed to a more current
version and I even have the option of
downloading now old versions that I
published and being able to open them up
back in my environment
so kind of a handy new feature that'll
be coming out of here shortly so lastly
let me show you right now I'm logged in
as a publisher but let me show you what
it looks like to log in some admin and
here mrs. admin panel data setting
you've got the metrics that are
available to you you can see kind of
what's going on on the server this you
can see as I was rendering my reports
there was a bit of a CPU spike on the
server a bit of an uptick in memory
usage and then it went back down so you
can kind of monitor kind of the the
usage of your server here you can see
how many users are registered on the
server processes that are running etc so
kind of a handy way to interact and
manage to the server we also include
audit log so as users make changes all
of this available tea right here in the
in ascetics panel so all of that is set
up there and I think that's the majority
of what I wanted to show you for the
demo so let me go back to the slides
here so well I'll leave you with is this
here they're additional resources so
well this is a commercial product we do
have a free 45 day trial and again you
can go down
that this link here at the top the admin
guide is available to you online
that'll be all the details are on how to
manage this or everything that I showed
you today is all available inside of the
admin guide and so you can probably you
know find the information that you're
looking for in there we do have a
particular document to the Q&A just for
IT folks so if you are kind of more IT
minded you have some questions around or
the IT infrastructure that's relevant
for connect there's a particular
document is for you
authentication if you're interested in
more authentication details you can find
that here and then lastly the release
notes as we make new versions available
will be posted here so you can view kind
of the differences between new versions
as we release some this your earlier so
that is effectively everything that I
have yeah so we do not have a third
functionality yet we will be introducing
that here in a coming release will have
a new feature for kind of a basic search
over for instance like titles and some
of the metadata of the content but we'd
be happy to and one of the things that
we're interested in is introducing a new
search feature that would be a little
bit more comprehensive and actually
include searching through the contents
of the document itself but that's
something that'll be a little bit longer
so that's actually attracting total RAM
usage and so that's the total server
usage but we do we are planning to have
deeper metrics on particular
applications so you can go in and see
the various metrics or the the different
applications for relevant to you you'd
be able to inspect their their rainiest
such as well yeah I think you know we
take very seriously the idea that we
should be preserving compatibility
between different versions and so so yes
you would you would definitely expect
your config files to be preserved and to
be continued to be usable across
different application so yes you
absolutely came to in the authentication
system I showed that there's a
particular configuration for LDAP that
would allow you to leverage LDAP groups
and if you're using LDAP groups from
that way then you can certainly say for
a particular document you know I should
that you can add a viewer or
collaborator by name you could also
reference LDAP groups or Active
Directory groups there and so you could
say a particular group has access your
viewership or collaborator access to a
document so basically some organizations
are going to say that an admin on our to
do connect is actually someone in IT who
may be less familiar with our but is you
know kind of managing the server and
managing the connect service itself so
that's one approach that you take in
that instance that there would be some
IT involvement where you might need to
be able to go in and configure and go in
and override some things on Kathak users
other organizations take the approach of
just empowering their data scientists to
be admins on the server and that does
have some implications that we'll get
into in the next webinar because an our
CTO kind of admin it is really a
powerful user on the server and they do
have some some pretty big permissions on
the server and so that is something that
you'll want to consider but it really
just depends on the organization in kind
of how you how you view add them some in
roles within the organization that's
something that's one of the more common
requests that we've heard and we don't
have that feature built in yet but that
is something that's definitely coming
down the road here we do have a couple
of different notions now that you can
actually export bundles which I showed
you that you can export all versions of
particular content now that you have
that beecher it is possible for you to
have kind of one connect environment
that you can kind of use as a sandbox
where people can kind of play and
develop and then you could export
content once you're happy with it you
could export content onto another server
that is you know thoroughly vetted or q8
or kind of your production environment
and so that is that is a possible
configuration that we see people using
currently connected as a single server
solution and so everything is running on
one box within Connect that is something
that we'll be tackling this year though
and we have two goals there both to
accomplish high availability and so that
you know if one server goes down you
still you still got uptime and you're
still online but also to establish
distributed computing and so you know to
to have kind of back-end workers that
aren't necessarily servicing web
requests that are able to run our
processes and
execute different our code there now
that being said it is certainly possible
you know at this flight all we're doing
is running our code behind the scenes
and so if you are you know if you're
using something like distributing our
code up to an HPC
or you know if you have some existing
mechanism by which you're distributing
computations in are we would not
encumber that in any way you would
certainly be able to continue to use
that but we don't we don't explicitly
facilitate that either today
[Music]